allez c'est parti
non il n'y a pas eu de pluie coloré à
Guyancourt la commune 50-hinoise
organisait tout simplement sa toute
première color run au cœur du quartier
de Villaroy on a passé un bon moment
voilà c'est festif c'est coloré et puis
voilà on est là pour pour faire cette
course de bonne humeur bah je trouvais
que c'était un super projet avec toute
l'histoire des couleurs qu'on nous lance
twist tu as vraiment un moment assez fun
entre amis ou en famille
on a terminé comme ça
en famille c'est très bien à faire une
course dont le mot d'ordre était de
s'amuser pas de classement pas de
chronomètre juste 5 km à parcourir avant
de découvrir de nombreux sports et arts
urbain on avait initié une première fête
des sports Urbains on a souhaité
effectivement l'étoffer avec un
rendez-vous qui deviendra maintenant
annuel un fil conducteur qui est cette
color run 350 particip a été inscrit
pour ce rendez-vous de quoi voir la vie
en couleur le temps d'une journée avant
d'aller se nettoyer la caméra elle aussi
y est passée